foreign
for Sam is that Sam in his own mind
imagines that he's perfectly consistent
right Sam is a bundle of contradictions
right a guy who believes that there is
exactly zero free will but that it is
very important that we be vigilant about
moral issues is in conflict with himself
now there's nothing wrong with that if
you say I believe these two things I
know them to be mutually exclusive I
believe they both have some truth and I
don't know how they reconcile I'm
interested I don't know but I'm not
giving up either one of these things
because I don't think either one of them
is so wrong that it needs to be thrown
out
right that's something you can hear
right you know or Jordan Peterson right
Jordan Peterson does this well right do
you believe you know in uh you know a
God who answers prayers
I act as if I do right right the point
is that's how you do this you
don't claim that my belief system is
consistent across the board you say
here's a Zone where I'm relatively
confident here's a Zone where I'm
relatively confident the thing in
between is a place I can't be confident
because I can see as well as anyone else
it doesn't fit right and so that that
ability to get from a low Peak to a
higher Peak is I believe tantamount to
how much of your own uncertainty you can
tolerate exactly right yes like you need
to be able to live in the uncertainty
and you know Frank part part of why for
instance people who have actually
traveled including you know immigrants
who've actually lived in two very
different countries but people who have
traveled and not just gone to the Disney
version of you know your home uh in
whatever place it is but actually
traveled
what you're doing is going into
uncertainty and saying I'm gonna have to
be okay with this and frankly people who
travel a lot are
indicating something about their
personality which says I'm more than
okay with this I I kind of love the
uncertainty I love the Serendipity I
love the opportunity to learn things
that I did not see coming yep and I will
uh if I can Pat myself on the back I
think one of my better skills one of the
reasons that I do well in this game is
that I have a Prater natural capacity to
file questions as open and leave them
there literally for decades sometimes
and the experience is you even forget
that you've got a question active it's
simmering so low on a back burner that
you don't even really think of it
but it isn't closed you haven't left to
a conclusion just to close it out
and then years later sometimes decades
later the thing that you didn't know
emerges and just the Cascade of like oh
that completes and then it has all of
these effects and the other things that
you weren't able to put together it's a
marvelous it's a marvelous uh experience
yeah and I think it really is a question
of
um we have a bad habit our bad habit is
leaping to conclusions and that happens
at every scale
um and basically to the extent that you
have that tendency
um it's it's an Achilles heel
and I would also say
that the flip side of this the way you
know we alluded to this earlier but the
way not to fall into this trap is very
socially dangerous but
straightforward which is to file things
as possibilities right so if we talk
about for example
conspiracy theories
you should be able to take every
conspiracy theory and you should be able
to say well what
I may believe let's take let's take a
good one right the moon landing was fake
I don't believe the moon landing was
fake I believe we landed on the moon I
believe it was a profoundly important
historical event but I don't rate the
chances that it was fake at zero right
in fact I've delved into that conspiracy
theory and I've noticed there are
actually some pieces of evidence in it I
don't know how to answer right things
that are important
so I have a very low probability that
actually what I was handed in terms of
the moon landing is obscuring another
truth right but just as when you would
ask our our boys when they were younger
they mostly don't need to be asked this
anymore right right at 18 and 16. uh you
know how certain are you of that
an answer of 100 or of zero percent is
basically a non-starter yep right so
there are things that you you know do I
have needs yeah I'm 100 sure of that
um but there is very little that goes
into any kind of complexity space that
you should rank as a zero percent or a
hundred percent well I gotta say the
knees you're gonna go after the knees
going after that I know as soon as I
said it awesome well the reason to do it
yeah of course as soon as you said it
you can spot and I'm sure given a minute
and a half you will find your own you
know reason to reserve a very tiny
percentage chance that you don't have
knees but uh well all right here but he
you you haven't heard this from me yet
I've been holding it back and I'm not
going to fully explore it here but I
will give you the tantalizing tidbit
um
I have been mocking people including
Elon Musk for his claim that there's a
good chance we're living in a simulation
okay
um for one thing his logic here which is
common to other people is garbage right
the logic is well the number of
simulations has to outnumber the number
of real universes by a huge amount
therefore statistically speaking this is
probably one right which is such a bad
argument right it's really really bad
because hey we don't know that there are
any simulations of any level of depth
that have ever existed so there may be
one universe and no simulations which
means that all the universes are real so
anyway whatever you can you can take
that apart however I had the very
uncomfortable experience
couple weeks ago of realizing that
although I still think the chances that
we are living in a simulation are really
really tiny that the chances that we are
living in a simulation took a giant leap
forward in my own understanding even
though I really don't like the idea and
will be so disappointed point of order I
feel like giant leap forward is like
Final Solution which one of these crazy
situations
even mounted and say giant leap forward
did he
um no so anyway it's some you know the
chances that we were living in a
simulation to me was like one in
ten thousand okay
um maybe put in a hundred thousand yeah
what happened
uh I realized that some
relatively commonly accepted
uh observations
are consistent with this in a way so
that I still think it's less than one
percent chance but it took a giant leap
in the right direction I will come back
to this I told you I'm not going to
provide the evidence yet I want to run
it by a couple of people and just make
sure that I'm not
you know I haven't lost my mind
um
okay
[Laughter]
because at the moment you sound like you
have right exactly exactly
[Music]